okay
thanks thank you very much well thank
you for all returning
the committee has considered all the
written evidence and the representations
made at the hearing
the committee has also considered the
conditions included within the
application for a variation
of the premises license and additional
conditions proposed
by environmental health and agreed by
the applicant
in order to promote the licensing
objectives
the committee has listened carefully to
concerns raised by the interested
parties relating to potential
for increased noise as a result of the
proposed use of the outside bar
and proposed live music in the outside
bar area
however the committee was sensitive to
the fact that no representations were
made
at the hearing by essex police and
environmental health
furthermore environmental health have
agreed conditions with the applicant
that they consider will serve to promote
the licensing objectives
the committee was also mindful of the
applicant's desire to run the premises
in a responsible way
to ensure that it is a family orientated
business that is more of a community
community asset than a late night
drinking venue
the committee has resolved to grant the
variation to the premises license
subject to the usual mandatory
conditions and
all it can do and all conditions agreed
with the environmental health are set
out in appendix c
to include a appropriate provision for
last orders to take place
in advance of the closure of the outside
bar
the conditions detailed within the
application form to vary a premises
license
set out in appendix a it is considered
that the combination of all these
conditions will serve to promote the
licensing objectives
the committee reminds all those present
at the application must adhere to all
the conditions applied to
to this variation of the premises
license and if there are any problems in
the future as a result of the grant of
this license
agree of the review of the license can
be requested
at any time this concludes the
hearing thank you all for attending
thank you very much